you just found yourself the tales of mr.
collector a limited-edition story
collection from doctor one detainment
I hate jail you know many times I've
been in jail since I started on this
journey twelve of course I always get
out eventually when there's no evidence
but hot damn does it suck
seriously even without the fear
instilled and dropping the salt the
rations are a harsh and the guards
always beat me they always say I looked
at them funny today I was walking down
the street and was stopped by two comps
they took me away to a lineup where the
witnesses had to choose the suspect the
suspect was described as a six foot two
asian male I'm a five-foot four
Caucasian of course being the suspicious
character I am I was chosen I don't even
know how to turn the safety off on a gun
let alone shoot somebody even back in
the day all the misters mistrusted me
one time I was taking a peeler to the
kitchen and mr. onion ran away and cried
in a corner I tried to assuage his fears
but instead he beat me up something
fierce said I was baiting him all I did
was ask him if he was okay red was the
only one who trusted me lie unlike your
chops he said to me one time hopefully
one day I'll see red again I hear he
might be where we're going
of course I didn't get to learn much
more because once they had the chance
everyone ran as fast as they could away
from me a child did that once when you
saw me on the street I waved at him and
he took it as a gesture to a hidden
group of snipers needless to say the
next minute I was
by his father who thought me a child
molester
what are they letting kids watch these
days anyways that gives them these ideas
I remember watching this movie and the
best by once where this guy was shooting
at snipers of course once the store
clerk saw me they called the police
one even decided it was time to take me
down himself with his black belt in
Taekwondo I went down like a sack of
bricks Jesus Christ my feet hurt I had
to see if a homeless shelter will take
me in for the night although the last
time I tried dad they thought I was a
drug dealer
even patted me down multiple times one
of them even did a cavity check maybe
I'll just sleep outside tonight
[Applause]
[Music]